Flying Dragon, The Secret Scroll, Kung Fu has never been this real.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
I don't really have...
Wait, what? Sorry, I was just going to say, what about real Kung Fu?
Isn't that as real, at least, as this?
Yeah, I guess, like, Kung Fu is already real, so it doesn't have to, like, get more real, right?
Right. Sorry, go on.
No, no, no. I guess that's a good...
I didn't have any topic prepared, so that's a good starting point for us here.
We're going to slowly develop the episode from here.
And I think that that is the best note to start on, is that Kung Fu is real, and people should know about it.
Dragons, not real, and have arms and legs.
They don't always have arms, but they usually have legs.
God, you do this on purpose.
I don't know what you mean, Mike.
I have no idea either.
I think it's time to start talking about video games.
I'm somewhat familiar with the idea of video games, more than I am familiar with Kung Fu.
But we've played our fair share of Kung Fu video games.
And, you know, Flying Dragon, The Secret Scroll is, like, a mixture of two different kinds of games.
It's half-side-scrolling action games, similar to, like, Final Fight, or...
I was thinking, for NES-specific, Kid Nicky Radical Ninja.
If anybody wants to do, like, a deep pullback.
Like, that game was very similar to this game.
But then there's also other stages, where it's just basically a fighting game, similar to Street Fighter.
Now, granted, it's not exactly like Street Fighter, because Street Fighter 2 hasn't perfected the fighting game system.
So they still have to figure out a way to handle that, and we'll get into that.
But I think it's interesting that we continue to see this trend of, like...
Specifically in 1989, of games being, like, no, you can't just be, like, one thing anymore.
You're either a bunch of minigames, or you're, like, mixing or fusing genres together.
Nothing really to add to that, but I was just wondering if you guys were expecting this to be, you know, more of a traditional fighter game...
Or, you know, an action-adventure game similar to, you know, the ones I referenced.
I was more expecting the side-scrolling element.
Just because, you know, I'd never heard of this game, and it just sort of seemed like, oh, here's another side-scroller, but here's another kung fu-flavored one.
And in the beginning, it sort of fell into that expectation, and I guess it would have more so if I didn't read the manual in here...
...and, like, read about what I was going to get into next.
But, yeah, I was originally thinking this would be just that one thing.
Yeah, I was thinking the same thing.
Even though, you know, at the beginning they do allude to the fact that you're, like, headed to a tournament.
So I sort of, at that point, was wondering what this tournament was going to be.
But I'll say I was expecting it to be a tournament where you take everything you've done in the side-scrolling levels...
...and now you're...it's like an evolution of it or another version of that.
But really, I was surprised that there's just two kind of gameplay styles that aren't really that related.
Yeah, they're actually so far apart in terms of, like, play style and just, you know, the flow of the game...
...that they actually make it a point to, when you get to the fighting part of it, to be like, actually, you have no idea what to do.
We need to give you a tutorial to explain what to do.
And they didn't do that at all for the side-scrolling action part, right?
They weren't like, hey, we should teach people about, like...
Punching and kicking.
Right, right. Or just, like, you know, what you need to do, right?
Of, like, you need to hit these tiki things or...
I can't remember what they are, but, like, these boxes and then they'll...
...things will appear from them.
Or you need to defeat, like, all five bosses.
Now, granted, that stuff's probably covered in the manual.
I didn't look at it.
But it's just a weird flow of something to be like, yeah, we understand that everybody knows how to do this part of the game.
And we're going to give you that first.
But then when we get to the other element of our game, we actually have to, like, stop and teach you, with an actual controller on screen, just the idea of doing this.
That was crazy.
Like, this is the first, like, on-screen tutorial I've ever seen, I think.
And it's done pretty fluidly.
I know that it stops the action in its tracks, but, I mean, like, it's intuitive.
It definitely is more useful than a poorly worded manual entry, and you just sort of have to parse the rest yourself.
Like, I thought that that was done relatively well.
Yeah, I really wanted to kind of praise that element of this game as well, because it does feel like, for the most part, if not always, we've so far had to go back to the manual anytime we were, like, confused about the controls or there was some new gameplay element introduced.
And like you said, Sean, sometimes that didn't translate perfectly to exactly, you know, you had to sort of figure it out.
And this did a really good job of teaching you, not only teaching you exactly how to do it, but, like, you know, there's a little bit of a, I don't want to say a learning curve.
It's a pretty simple concept, but, like, at least a learning curve is in terms of your muscle memory.
And it gives you a good, like, the tutorial doesn't just teach you exactly how to do it.
It gives you some time to learn it, so you feel like when you're done with that tutorial, you've kind of upped your skill a little bit to where you feel like you're equipped to go on and actually fight the tournaments.
So I thought they did a good job with that.
Yeah, and I think it also just shows how new of an idea this is to, like, video games that they felt the need to, you know, stop all the gameplay and action and progress and be like, here's how you're going to do these things.
And, you know, that's really the biggest takeaway for me was just that, you know, it hasn't been perfected yet how we do, like, one-on-one combat, right?
Like, we've seen wrestling games handle it one way, other games handle it via, like, menu systems.
Nobody's quite figured out yet, like, the idea of you and your opponent having different sets of moves and each having, like, a health bar that corresponds.
But I think this comes really close.
I actually question, you know, like, they came so close, but they didn't because they didn't figure it out, right?
It's like some people will be disappointed.
But I don't think this is, like, the wrong way to go either.
So if you don't mind, I'm going to actually, like, push aside the side-scrolling levels for right now, even though the game starts with them, because I feel like that's just something easier to get into.
I want to talk about the fighting game levels, because since this isn't your traditional fighting game, you have these targets that indicate what kind of button input you need to do.
What did you guys think of that idea versus, you know, traditional Street Fighter, Tekken, Mortal Kombat-style games where, you know, you're in complete control of the inputs that you do, but you kind of need to, like, memorize these awesome inputs.
Whereas this game says, like, you don't really have control over what input you're going to do next, but you have to remember these patterns.
And then by doing these things with the limited controller that you have, right, you only have the D-pad and the two buttons, you'll be able to do, you know, more awesome things than you'd be able to if we just gave you one-button punches, one-button kicks.
Yeah, I mean, it's definitely approaching, like, the quote-unquote fighting game from a different angle than we're used to.
It's almost more like a Simon Says slash rhythm game sort of thing where, yeah, these targets appear on your body and your opponent's body, and they sort of telegraph where you should hit as, like, a weak spot or where your opponent is going to hit that you need to defend.
And I think it still works.
It works pretty well as an idea.
And then when you're actually fighting and you sort of get into that rhythm, like, even the idea of, like, a combo sort of shows itself.
It's a very simple one, but, like, even your standard inputs are kind of a combo because you have to target, like, these different parts of your opponent's body.
But then you get slightly more complex ones where, like, with your sort of grab them and throw them over your head sort of thing.
So there's a lot of elements that sort of will evolve as the fighting game genre evolves, but also stuff that'll just completely get thrown away, like this whole, like, they show you a target and you have to hit it sort of thing.
But it's still very unique.
Yeah, I thought the target thing, it helped to bring a lot to the table, but there was also, I think it compromised a lot of other things, too.
So for one, because they're trying to kind of, I feel like, capture the spirit of, you know, of a martial arts, you know, sparring one-on-one match, this target system kind of gives you control over things like, okay, where do I want my guard to be?
Do I want to be blocking high, middle, low?
Where do I want to kick?
Like, where is he blocking?
Where it's like, I guess that translates decently to what it would be like to be in an actual, like, martial arts fight where you're thinking of, like, okay, he's dropped his guard, I go for the head.
Okay, his guard's up, sweep the legs, whatever.
So that's nice.
And as, you know, just the way that it presents itself where these targets appear and you have to hit the target as it appears or you see where they're aiming and you have to block before they hit you, it lends itself to having a nice, fluid, what feels like a martial arts style fight as opposed to just, like, punch, punch, punch, punch.
It's like a little more of, like, a dance, you know?
And that's nice. I think that that works and you really get into a rhythm as you're playing.
What I think it loses is that even though you get more control over exactly where you're hitting and stuff, you lose pretty much all agency in the battle.
You know, it's all about doing what it says is the best move at the right time.
It's all about timing.
It is almost more of a rhythm game in the sense that it's just kind of a series of almost quick time events.
Yeah. And when you describe it as a dance, like, those targets really just are your choreography.
Like, yeah, you're not making any strategic decision about I should bait and then hit.
You're just sort of doing what the game tells you to do.
Exactly. And I think that that, for me, over time, started to slowly outweigh the appreciation I had for how cool it felt to fight this way.
After a while, I was like, okay, I'm kind of bored now.
I'm just doing what the game tells me.
The game is playing me.
Whoa. The fighting game that we've also compared to a rhythm game, Mike Tyson's Punch-Out, you know, that game, completely different graphical style that they were able to pull it off.
But, like, imagine if instead of these, like, great animation tells that you have to look out for and, you know, subtle tricks in the audience or flashes or stuff like that.
Imagine if instead they just, like, had a big dot over the fist when it was about to, like, punch this way you knew to dodge, right?
It's, like, it's kind of like that in a way, but I don't know how, because this is, you know, a 2D from the side action fighting game.
I don't know how they would be able to communicate, like, such great tells in the combat that it wouldn't just be reduced to the kind of combat that you get during the side-scrolling action stages, you know, where you're just, like, constantly just hitting punch and kick and hoping your punch and kicks outweigh the opponents, you know, and it just becomes like a spamming battle.
So, because they had to come up with some kind of system to, like, create a more nuanced fighting system where it's actually like, you know, hey, you're responsible for both blocking and attacking, dependent on what, you know, what we show you on screen.
I'm not sure how else they could have pulled that off, but at the same time, you know, I'm not ready to applaud that either because I do agree that, you know, you are just answering their commands.
But also, like, you're less inclined to just, like, experiment in general, not even because you can't, but, like, I don't know about you guys.
I didn't even think I could move.
Like, I found out later on you can move, but, like, I couldn't think of a reason for why I'd really want to move.
There's no, like, grand reason for, you know, for space control or anything like that.
Like, you still have to, when the dots finally do show up in the locations they do, you still have to answer the same call.
Yeah. So, I mean, in terms of movement, like, yeah, it's not really well utilized because there's, like, you can dodge out of the way of certain attacks that have enough, like, lead time.
But the thing about this game is I agree with you.
Like, this was put into place because having it be more of, like, a standard fighter in, like, the standard word that we're thinking of.
Like, the controls just aren't there.
Like, even though you're being told what to do, they still kind of feel sticky.
And I don't know if you, I guess it's kind of subjective.
Maybe you guys didn't feel that way.
But to me, they felt kind of sticky because the other solution, like, just playing armchair designer that I can think of to allow for more information to be given to you that isn't just an explicit target.
Um, could be solved by just zooming in more.
And that would make movement even less important.
Um, jumping and stuff less important.
And so that, like, these larger sprites that you're seeing for, uh, yourself and your opponent could have more telegraphing information or, uh, just as a tell.
Work as a tell or, uh, something along those lines.
But I understand that, like, if this is how the game feels, um, in its current state, then I don't think that just blowing it up would make it feel any better.
Um, so I don't know.
I guess I'm just sort of rambling about, like, the wider design of the game, uh, in terms of, like, why they went that way.
Yeah, it's an interesting idea, though, the idea of, of blowing it up and then taking away the actual, like, icons on the screen and making the tells actual tells.
Right? Because, you know, ever since, ever since Mike brought up Punch-Out!, I've been thinking about that where I'm like, why do I like Punch-Out!
so much better than I like this?
Because it is technically, if you really want to read into it, it is an indicator on the screen that tells you what to do.
But there's something, one, about the immersion of something like Punch-Out!, where it's like you feel like you're actually fighting that person.
And two, it's a little more complex than just, than just the dot telling you where to hit.
So it's like, you know, it's a little more, like, real-life decision-making based on what you're seeing.
Well, obviously, it's still a pattern.
But, like, so are almost every boss battle in any modern video game you play is all pattern recognition.
And I think that, you know, it's like Punch-Out!
or something like what you're describing, Sean, about a possible way to do this,
is getting closer to just complex patterns instead of a pattern of blue dot, red dot.
You know, where it's just, like, literally, press this button now, press this button now.
That's what makes this feel, to me, like I'm not thinking.
You know, the game is thinking for me.
Yeah, it's important to remember that the dot here isn't just telling you, like, oh, hit their stomach or hit them in the head.
It's telling you, just based on the way that the game, you know, sets up the tutorial for you, too,
it's telling you which buttons to press on your controller.
So you don't even get the choice now of, like, they're saying go for the head and I want to do a strong kick.
Like, no, you have to do the same exact inputs that a dot on that person's head means versus a dot on your head.
Like, they're deciding what controller input you do, so you're just reacting.
And even in the, you know, as the game continues, any additional things they add to the fighting,
like they add some additional special moves and eventually there's an elimination round and stuff like that,
it's actually all just story progress.
It doesn't actually enhance the actual fights any further because, specifically for the elimination round, right,
they show you this great, like, bracket of best of eight or whatever, right,
and, like, you move up in the tournament.
And, you know, that's great and compelling as, like, wow, I got to make my way through this.
But every match in this game is an elimination round thing where, like, if you lose, you lose, and that's game over.
It's just window dressing the whole tree.
Right, exactly. It's just dressing it up.
But you could argue that the special moves are just doing that too, really.
They're not, like, you know, there's that one where you do, like, a flying kick in the air where you're spinning around
and then you come down and hit them.
That doesn't actually change anything in the game other than now you know this technique,
but you can still only use it when we call for it, you know?
Yeah. And I think another important thing to mention with these dots is since it's reactionary,
it's kind of demanding on the reactionary side.
I don't think it's, like, so fast that it's impossible by any means.
And you don't want to be perfect, right?
That'd be kind of a boring game too.
You want to make a mistake every now and again, so you don't want it to be, like,
you have all the time in the world.
However, the amount of times that you have to, you know, react to these dots on an individual fight level
is just, like, that's a lot in itself.
But then to just continue to have to be on edge for this kind of thing,
like, I don't know if this dot system is really pulling off the longer you play it.
I don't know if you guys feel that way about the reaction times,
but it's just, like, as soon as you strike or block what they want you to do,
there's immediately a new dot on screen requiring the next set of inputs.
Yeah. And, like, again, like, I think we've been, the way we've been pitching this game,
it sort of sounds like it plays itself and it's super easy.
And what you just said is why it's not,
because while it is more just a test of reaction time and not so much fighting strategy,
that is still very challenging.
One could argue that it's not a very engaging way to be challenging, but you're right.
Like, as the fights progress, it becomes a lot harder to sort of keep up
and to dodge as well as you should.
So, yeah, I agree.
It's demanding.
Yeah, I think the other thing that makes it, that still makes it challenging is that,
so I know I'm going to get this backwards or somehow messed up,
but something to the effect of when you're defending,
you have to just press the D-pad button in the direction you're defending,
but when you're attacking, you have to press the D-pad plus A
in the direction you want to attack on them,
which sounds pretty simple,
but it does become a little bit of, like, a pat your head, rub your stomach situation sometimes,
where you're like, wait, what am I doing?
So, like, you get into this rhythm and it feels really good,
and then when you slip out, like, once, suddenly you're like,
ah, like, you're kind of, like, caught on your back foot for a second.
And, you know, that part, you know, that element of it is cool at first, you know,
but it's just, I don't think it's interesting enough to hold my attention
for the amount of time it wants me to do it.
Yeah, it's kind of necessary for them to break up these fights
with these side-scrolling levels,
because otherwise that would be the whole game, right?
It's just constantly, like, how much better, you know,
I think Sean put it perfectly when he said it's like Simon says,
because, you know, how long can you keep up with that?
Like, how long is that interesting?
Even if the animations change,
if the core concept remains the same forever,
it just becomes harder to go on.
Right, right. Did you guys try the pause strategy at all?
The pause strategy?
Sounds like a strategy I would like.
Yeah, I'm surprised, Joe, that you didn't know about it,
but in order to really make my way through this game
and, you know, just keep my interest levels up,
I found on GameFAQs that there is a whole strategy to the fighting
based around pausing,
and that is that as soon as you defend or attack, you know,
the dot on screen,
because the next one pops up,
you can actually pause the screen,
the dot remains,
and now you know the next queue up attack.
Oh, that sounds so fun.
No, it's not fun.
It's not fun. I'm saying in order for me to continue on with the game,
you know, in the later levels and everything,
it's a strategy that is not fun at all,
but I also just can't believe that
they would allow the dot to remain on the pause.
Like, it seems like such an easy thing to just, like,
if you pause, just, like, remove even just that one sprite
or just cover it, right?
Like, have the pause thing be, like,
enough to cover the field of action or something.
Like, I think it's just, it's incredibly tedious,
don't get me wrong. Like, it's definitely, like,
the game isn't encouraging it by any means.
But, you know, if anything, it draws out, like,
at least... I just can't believe people, like,
played like that enough to consider it, like,
a valid strategy.
Yes, I know. Yeah.
Well, if you think about it, though, right,
it's like, if you're trying to beat every NES game,
sooner or later, you're gonna come up with ways
to cheese any particular game
that you're struggling with, right?
Like, we've figured out all sorts of things,
and I'm not encouraging this strategy by any means
because, like I said, it adds actually so much extra time to these fights
and it doesn't enhance the game at all
because, again, you're just saying now, like,
oh, cool, now I know I have to do, you know,
D-pad up and A.
And that doesn't, like, to me,
that sounds like nonsense.
So not something I would recommend,
but just a funny exploit
because it completely removes any actual challenge.
It's almost like having an invincibility code
built into the game.
Yeah, it's kind of like,
if you take away the live,
not live, but the action version,
the action element to this,
you're just, you're literally just putting in inputs
every couple seconds.
You're like, all right, time to put in that next input,
unpause, put in the input, pause.
All right, what's next?
Like, put in this input.
You're not playing a game anymore.
It's not even, it's like worse than other types of cheating
because you're literally not even playing a game.
You're just, you're just every couple seconds
putting in a new input that the game tells you to do.
You're playing keep talking and nobody explodes with the game.
Yeah, exactly.
Except you can't really lose.
Right, right. All right, I feel like that's enough
on the fighting game section
and we can move on to the side-scrolling levels.
As I threw out a throwback episode
to Kid Nikki Radical Ninja,
do you guys even remember that game?
Nope. Yeah, that was the one you had,
you could go in different order of the levels, right?
Yes. Yeah, I remember that one.
Yeah, so don't remember that part,
but just the look and feel
of the side-scrolling action of it
is what I remember most from this.
But these side-scrolling levels are,
they're wraparounds. Yeah.
You'll just constantly, you know,
it's like you're going on a treadmill
through the same set over and over and over again.
And there are bosses.
I don't know why they call them bosses.
They might as well just be like enemies
with slightly more health
is what I would refer to them as.
But the screen goes like dark for them,
which is kind of cool. It's like it makes it feel like
a little bit of a bigger fight.
But these are the things that you experience
in these side-scrolling levels
is they're short, small stages
where you have to kind of figure out
where the bosses are,
defeat all of them,
where the hidden items are.
And then lastly, once you've defeated all five bosses,
where's the key in the stage
so that I can unlock the door?
Well, all right.
Let me give a little brief rundown of this.
Please. So there's no hidden anything.
Like there's some hidden like health packs
and like many power-ups
in the statues that are littered
across the field.
But the thing that triggers each
like actual power-up
and finding the key
to exit the side-scrolling level
is just kill five enemies in a row.
You kill five enemies in a row
and a boss comes out
and then you kill the boss
and you get the little piece of,
I don't know, kanji or whatever the Chinese equivalent is.
And then you get your little power-up
or key and then you move on to the next one.
You kill five more enemies in a row
and you fight the thing again.
You do it five times.
And that sounds like it takes a while,
but it doesn't because the game is incredibly simple
and easy in this mode.
And then you just rinse and repeat
until you have everything
and then you just go to the door,
which is clearly marked as the door,
and you go to the next tournament.
And my biggest question about this part
is why they even bother
contextualizing the things
that you're picking up as power-ups
because you have to get one,
you have to get them all in order
and then the key
in order to progress
and you don't get to keep anything.
As soon as you get to the fight,
you are now in competition mode
and what you did in the side-scroller
doesn't really matter.
So it just felt tacked on.
Just to do what you described earlier, Mike,
of just give you a break
from the more strenuous
one-on-one fighting,
it just seems half-baked the whole time.
Yeah, I didn't realize
that it was killing five enemies
that triggered the boss to come.
But I did quickly realize
that I didn't have to actually move
anywhere in the level. I was like,
if I just stand here and fight for a minute,
I thought it was time-based or whatever,
but if I just stand here
and fight for a minute, the boss will show up.
So I guess I was killing five enemies.
But that also kind of made me think,
what's the point of this whole level?
I don't have to go anywhere.
I can just stand right here
and everything I need will come to me.
I gotta find the door,
but that's fine. So it's not that big of a level.
Usually the door is pretty early on.
And then there's all this other stuff
that they put in these levels
that you don't need to go to.
But Joe, just even now knowing
that I didn't have to explore the level,
I prefer the way you guys were playing it.
I think that it's such a chore
to play as this character
in these side-scrolling levels,
maybe specifically just because
you have to hit the up on the D-pad to jump,
and I just thought we were done with those days.
But it's so bad here.
It's frustrating because the jump,
it's like you definitely can't do
multiple inputs at once
for whatever it's worth anyway.
But something about moving forward
and also having to jump,
because you have to, so you're holding right on the D-pad
and they can't register moving right
and jumping at the same time.
But there's pitfalls
and there's platforms to get onto.
That just made everything
infinitely worse.
And if I would have known
that I didn't have to move
from where my comfort zone was
and I could just stay there
and have everybody come to me,
I would have preferred that
because the worst part
about this part of the game,
the platforming, if you will,
just moving from the different layers
and things that you experience
throughout the level,
doing that over and over
and over again too,
because it's just a short loop
before you go back to the beginning,
doing that over and over again,
I wish I would have just not had
to have dealt with that
or just put us in a tournament area,
but this time it's not
with the martial arts rules.
Now you're out there in the wild
so you can just attack
the way that you attack.
It's like don't give me free range
to explore this thing
because I'm not interested in exploring it.
Yeah, I'm just going to clarify
that I think you only prefer it that way
because you didn't like
the experience at all.
I think if it was an engaging
part of the game
and you found out
there's a huge shortcut
that would actually bum you out.
But yeah, just want to clarify that.
Yeah, but that's an interesting point too,
not even that I didn't enjoy it.
It's an interesting point to mention
that the whole game
is just kind of rules-based on things
and we continue to find ways
to just exploit that very obviously.
Like they never actually designed anything
to your point, Sean,
of that it's just kill five enemies
and then the boss appears
and there's no like hidden area
to find a boss
or hidden place to find a key
because it's just all like
you know, set up for you
in this structure over and over again.
Whether it's the fighting levels
or the exploration levels,
you can just figure out
like the fastest way
to get through all this stuff
or the most efficient way
for your play style
to get through all this stuff
without having to actually play
the game much at all.
Yeah. And I don't know what it was
about the boss fight.
I don't know why we're still calling them boss fights
but like I don't know why
what it was but like they weren't challenging
maybe because
you have like a good amount of health
and if you do explore,
you can find,
I don't know, I guess there's soda bottles
or milk bottles. You can find easy ways
to replenish your energy
back to full.
So I never really felt like
I was in danger
during these stages.
I was definitely losing
more health
in the fighting game stages
because even in the boss fights
you're encouraged to just like,
I don't know, take a little chunk of damage
here and there just to get up close
and personal with them, right?
Like just take them out quicker
than trying to like
block their attacks
or dodge their attacks
and then go in for the strike.
It's like, if you can take them out
in four rapid strikes,
you're better off taking a little bit of health off
and just getting rid of them early.
Yeah, because you don't carry
your health into your next
like competition
and the only thing
that separates these bosses
from standard enemies
is that they aren't just
mindlessly walking forward.
They've got projectiles
and they reposition
but like by the time
you fight these things
at least the later ones
like you will probably
have come across like a power-up
that gives you a projectile
or a little force field
that you can just stand
in front of them and it'll kill them
in like seconds.
So it's just, it's not very well balanced.
It's just like you can
easily cheese the section
so it may as well not exist.
Yeah, you know how
like we talk about sometimes
difficulty in a game
coming down to like
was the bad guy,
was the boss well designed
or was it like
oh he just has so much health
like they made it harder
by just giving him
a bunch of health or making him do
a ton of damage. It's almost like
artificially inflating
the difficulty of a boss battle
and I think that this game
is like the reverse of that.
It's easy but not because you can do
a bunch of cool shit or you get all these
cool power-ups. It's just easy
because you have way more health
and do more damage
or your health doesn't go
that you have just way higher defense
and do more damage so you can just kind of
run in and like
and just sort of
kamikaze the enemy
and like they
they you're
they're gonna die before you die
all five of them
or whatever before you lose
all of your health and then like you said
they don't your health doesn't
carry over to
to the next
fighting tournament round
like nothing about
nothing about
the side-scrolling
round is in any way
connected to the tournament round
there are two separate games
on the same cartridge
now imagine playing
these two separate
games and doing
them you know one after the
other after the other without much
really changing between between
the the two modes
when you get to
the end of the game
it does that
classic you know
you're not
you know like you're not
done you actually have
to go through the whole game
again this time
instead of just finding the keys
and stuff now you have to
find the four
crystal balls
and they made it
so this way the crystal balls
cannot be found
obviously in your first
playthrough you have to be
on the second
playthrough I didn't bother
with this but
from what I can
understand the game
isn't any more
challenging other than
the amount of health
that comes
off so granted that is a
bigger deal
right but that's not the kind
of modifier I like
now I'm not
sure what else they would have
done I'm not you know
I'm not saying like give me new
levels or anything
because they would have just ultimately
been the same thing
but I don't
think there's enough incentive
there if you know
if you go through all this to do
it again just like how
I kind of didn't feel
Ghost and Goblins
earned it either right like it's
such a challenging game and then
they say do it
all again to get the true
ending you know
I don't know if these games
that change so
little other than
just like great you did it once
prove you're really
good and do it twice it's like
no I proved I
was really good
when I did it
the first time right like this
is your game this is all you
had to offer you're not
offering me anything new
in the second
playthrough I don't
know yeah bothers me a
little bit I agree I mean I
think that this
trend that I
don't know if it's really a trend but the
thing that this
game does only
really works in
like the more modern like
roguelike games
where that's just
built into like
the gameplay itself whereas
in any any
standard like
get to the end
fight the final
boss and and
and win game
it's just a cop
out and an obvious time
extension tool so
I don't think yeah you're right
got a ghost and
goblins did not
earn it I don't
think any game has earned it
that like that
operates like
that yeah there
would need to be something in the
in the there would
need to be a new game plus almost you
know there would need to be something
in it where it's like oh I got to
keep all these power-ups I had or
or like some new
yeah new I mean I
know we said that this is maybe like a
big ask but like new
levels or something
new to do if you're
going to tell me that I can't beat
the game unless I do
it all over again
yeah yeah and I'm
totally a fan of new
game plus stuff I'm
not expecting that
in these NES games but you got the
true ending that
first time yeah I
don't think like that's lame I think
that's a fun way for
someone who's really good at the game to
experience the game all over again with
all the stuff that
they acquired like you
know even if you don't do it that way whatever
you choose to do I
think like that that
way of flushing it out is a lot better
than saying you didn't
really beat the game
but offering no
changes I think about
Super Mario Galaxy has
a thing where like you
know you have to collect the first
hundred and twenty
stars in that game
and then you can unlock Luigi and you
play the same exact
game again except for
he just has a slightly
higher jump that's the
only difference but
they never said you
didn't beat the game
so yeah it's not quite
like new game plus
territory because it's
such a small change
but like no one's
forcing you to be like
well if you want the real ending you know
you got to play the whole game as Luigi
again it's like that's
what I feel like this game should have done
is like they should
have given everybody the ending but now
you've unlocked the
more difficult mode
right yeah you know
that's the only change
is like now you can play on the harder
difficulty and prove
your skill rather than
prove you beat the
game like I did prove
I beat the game yeah it should be more
like incentive to play
it again rather than
just saying nope you're
not done if you didn't
beat it like not
enough care it people a reason to
start over and say
it again not
enough carrot too
much stick yeah
one thing I wanted
to shout out for the
like setting of the
game and stuff like that is that the
locations do change
and even the fighting
part of the game does
change locations too
to the point where a
certain part of the
game you're facing
boxers and I thought
that was like even
though they don't act any differently or
anything I thought there was like a
neat change right
something you would
see in a an anime or
a manga or something like that a karate guy
taking on a bunch of
boxers or something like that you're in a
wrestling ring I thought
that was a fun addition
to this like being in
the city or being in
the forest they didn't
get too lazy and just
all make it like the
same location all the
time and the only thing that changes is the
color yeah I think the
game has good presentation for the
most part and and
just the fact that there are different
arenas is is it is
enough for me to be
honest but yeah there's
a lot more polish to
this game than there is
substance for the sequels and
spinoffs flying dragon
actually does have it's a
whole like series
actually in Japan I
think it's called hero
no ken and here it's
flying dragon but flying
dragon had a prequel
first called Shanghai
kid only in the arcades
and it's just the the
fighting game part of
it if I recall correctly
so this is just kind of
a spiritual successor
for the consoles with
flying dragon but then
the other games all get
the flying dragon title
and there's a bunch of
them so I'm not really going to get into it too
much but I you know
interesting observation
when Street Fighter
finally does come out
after that all the
fighting elements of
their games you know
whether it's for Super Nintendo or N64 like
they just rip off the
Street Fighter format
they completely abandon
their dot system and
you know trying to
expand upon that with
like a better understanding of like
what fading games are
now and they say no
instead just make it
exactly like Street
Fighter you know just
if it ain't if that's
what's working let's
just copy that let's
surrender our idea
yeah I mean I think
that I haven't played
these games but I
want to say that
it's less like let's
just copy Street Fighter
and more like this is
now the genre codifier
and what we were doing
was wrong yeah
Street Fighter figured
it out I mean I don't think that that
should that should mean
that that's the only way to do it but that
was like you know at
the time it's like okay that's the only way
that anyone's figured out are we gonna take
a risk and try something
crazy and new and have
it most likely be not
as good or do we just
stick with the with
the formula yeah it's
an interesting observation
because I mean I don't want to get into too
much of other fighting games but Mortal Kombat
is still kind of just
Street Fighter but with
more gore and some
you know interesting
weapon choices right
like it's it doesn't
change too much other
than like adding a fatality at the end
which is a you know neat new addition but
it's a small addition
in the grand scheme of things whereas you have
games like Tekken that
actually do learn
something from Street Fighter but say like
well what if you could actually move around in
the space you know like
what if what if that was
the change and so you
could go either way with
it right but ultimately
yeah once Street Fighter
lays down the groundwork
for like how to do these
kinds of games it would
be silly to keep the dot
system in and just make
this a reaction based
game because essentially
you know all video games
are on one level or
another are reaction
based games it's just
they usually don't tell
you what input to do
next and and that
being said though like
things like Tekken and
I guess not not so much
Soul Calibur but
definitely with Tekken
like that that is an
evolution that was only
made possible by new
technology right and
Virtua Fighter for that
matter yeah yeah but
interesting that Street Fighter continues to to
avoid that right yeah
they say like no that's
Tekken or you know
whatever you know Soul
Calibur that's those games
and we do ours this way
and then you have like
King of Fighters you
know following in line
with that too and yeah all right we're
gonna do something our
way that we always do at
the end of an episode and
that is the essential
games list Sean your vote for Flying
Dragon the Secret
Scroll uh well obviously what I've
been saying has kind of
uh tipped everyone off to
how I'm going to vote
here I I it's definitely
uh it's definitely unique
and it's building up to
something in terms of
like this proto fighting
game um but it's got too
much flab and it's it's
just not all that
enjoyable after a little
while um with the whole
you know Simon says uh
monkey see monkey do punch
me in the face how about
you uh not essential
Joe monkey see monkey do
how do you vote well
speaking of that I I
guess it's time that we
let the listeners know
that when we when we
vote for the essential games list you know
Mike you'll say Joe and
then Mike holds up like a
red target if he wants me
to vote it essential
blue target if he wants
me to vote it not essential so I'm just
waiting for that target to
be held up because I we
have no agency so Mike
show you're held against
your will yeah Mike has
hold held up the blue
target which means I'm
going to vote it not
essential and I I think
that all seriousness I
think that the only thing personally for me worth
talking about about this
game is the fighting
section the side
scrolling section just
another side scrolling section and it's got
plenty of flaws and it
you know doesn't doesn't
do enough here I am
talking about it even
though I said it's not worth talking about but
the the fighting section
it did it did hold my
interest at first and I
was like oh this is cool and it's fun to get
into that rhythm it's
just not enough to hold
my interest for the amount it wants you to
to the amount of levels
or the amount of battles
it wants you to face
using these reaction
commands it just needs
something more to me so
I'm saying not
essential all right well
thank you for listening
to the blue dot instead
of always yeah and you
know it's always the blue dot actually whenever
anybody says any game I
say not essential that's
my new thing I'm
keeping the essential games list it is
perfect and we will not
be adding any other games to it including
flying dragon the secret
scroll no it we're just
happy that flying dragon
the secret skull doesn't
even have a chance right
like thank goodness
Sean and Joe voted
correctly so that this
way it doesn't fall on
me but no it's not
going on the essential games list will
something go on the essential games list in
2022 I don't know it
remains to be seen right
we're going through quite
an onslaught of games
here but you know we'll
see because for all I
know a game that
already we already
played is on the
essential games list but
I don't know that yet because I'm confused
about time and space
huh if you don't want to
be confused about time and space all you need
to know is that new
episodes every Friday of
this show that's right
if you're surprised by
that I'm I'm a little
worried because it's
always been that way but
next week we're gonna have Jordan verse bird
one-on-one and if you
don't know who Jordan or bird is don't worry
we're gonna explain that
in the episode we have
you covered on all
things Jordan bird and
what one-on-one means as
well we will go in depth
on those topics just like
we always do on
nostalgia for more
nostalgia visit www.nestalgiacast.com
if you want access to
exclusive stuff check out
our patreon patreon.com
slash nostalgia or if you
just want to like talk to
us about nostalgia related
things tweet at us at
nostalgia cast I'm wait
wait guys guys we didn't
talk about the story of
the game do we think that's worth talking about
I don't think so
you think so Thank you.